podría la búsqueda de vida
extraterrestre y llevarnos directamente
al vecino de la tierra un equipo
internacional de científicos ha
descubierto un marcador clave de
actividad microbiana en la atmósfera de
venus la fosfina un gas nocivo es común
en planetas gigantes gaseosos como
júpiter pero en planetas rocosos más
pequeños como la tierra y teóricamente
venus la cocina se produce en la
naturaleza sólo cuando es producida por
pequeños organismos vivos winborg
trabajamos toda la química toda la
química conocida posible que podría
ocurrir en la atmósfera de venus en la
superficie y en el subsuelo y ni un solo
proceso que mirábamos podría producir
fosfina en cantidades suficientes para
explicar los hallazgos de nuestro equipo
sobre la cocina en la atmósfera de
ventas o ser nombrado por la diosa
romana de la belleza y el amor
venus es uno de los objetos más
brillantes visibles en el cielo nocturno
pero sus ópticas de albergar vida
extraterrestre han sido consideradas por
mucho tiempo bastante escasas envuelto
en una espesa y tóxica atmósfera bajo
nubes de ácido sulfúrico las
temperaturas en la superficie del
planeta pueden alcanzar los 470 grados
centígrados pero la atmósfera superior
del planeta podría ser habitable para
los microbios anaeróbicos que no
necesitan oxígeno y a menudo prosperan
en condiciones extremas por lo tanto
muchos científicos siguen siendo
escépticos pero los últimos hallazgos
han intrigado a la comunidad científica
hasta el punto que el actual
administrador de la nasa dijo que ahora
es necesario priorizar a venus